around the world and talk to businesses
bullied by the success of getting a
difficult deal with the EU done Richie
sunac visited Northern Ireland on
Tuesday to sell it and I'm really
pleased in fact I'm over the moon that
yesterday we managed to have a decisive
breakthrough with our negotiations with
the EU reached agreement the New Windsor
framework that I think is an
extraordinary positive set for Northern
Ireland the UK prime minister met local
Business Leaders at the Coca-Cola
factory in Lisbon and his pitch was as
fizzy as the drinks he stood in front of
but see if you can spot what's caught
the attention of remainers across the
land
Northern Ireland is in the unbelievably
special position unique position in the
entire world European continent in
having privileged access
not just to the UK Home Market which is
enormous fifth biggest in the world but
also the European Union single Market
nobody else has that
no one
only you guys only here
and that is the prize
of course it was a very similar prize
that the rest of the UK gave up with
brexit
The Windsor framework changes the
problematic Northern Ireland protocol an
earlier deal with the EU which
established trade barriers between
Northern Ireland and Mainland UK and so
angered Northern Ireland's unionists
that they collapsed the power sharing
government a year ago they'll need to be
happy with the New Deal to come back to
the Stormont assembly we listened very
carefully to what the Prime Minister
said but we need to translate that into
what the legal text actually says what
does it mean for business what does it
mean for consumers and fundamentally
what does it mean for Northlands place
within the United Kingdom and our
ability to trade within the internal
Market of the UK although they're not
going to be bounced into a quick
decision the dup will be feeling the
pressure particularly if the deal
continues to receive widespread approval
the longer that the dup are seen as a
block on functioning government here at
Stormont the less happy voters are going
to feel about them
you can feel the frustration at all of
Smith's chain of cafes so businesswoman
wants to see the back of sectarian
politics here where Health Services
getting worse our educational under
achievement is getting worse our poverty
is getting worse the class divide
between those that have and those that
have not is getting bigger so you know
storm into something running tomorrow
will that change that only if they put
those issues at the top of their
political agenda The Windsor framework
the Northern Ireland protocol unionist
nationalist such matters are less
important to many people in Northern
Ireland these days than just getting
things to work properly Rory challenge
Al Jazeera Belfast